all right this next story should not be
a story rumor the Orville's Seth
MacFarlane and NBC walk out of Star Trek
sales meeting I love Star Trek Seth
MacFarlane's a freaking genius man and
the Orville is better in my opinion I
gotta be I gotta be honest I did not
watch a lot of the new Star Trek because
discovery yeah because I've watched a
few minutes and been like really I liked
it I saw the first season and you liked
it I did I like you know that like
apparently they got accused of stealing
the idea from some video game called
tardigrades never heard of the video
game but it's like an old video game
like a Doss or like Windows game where
you can travel around the universe or
the galaxy using the Narvik yeah the
network order and then and that's what
discovery was like right yeah basically
yeah which is really weird considering
Star Trek was always about warp
technology and they seemingly injected
this weird storyline into it well it's
it's the next evolution of warp
technology basically it's it's where
they I'm just there's a network that
connects basically the entire universe
and they can ride along it it's kind of
with that you know I want to spoil but
what about the board network remember no
I don't remember was that ah that was uh
that was into Voyager that's some
traveling transwarp corridors yeah and
so the Borg had transwarp corridors I
never finished anyway anyway the story
is a 4chan rumor and here's my favorite
favorite media like double standard if
someone on 4chan says guys Seth
MacFarlane had a meeting with NBC it's a
rumor yeah but if someone says guys
Bernie Sanders is being robbed by the
DNC it's a conspiracy that's funny and
so they will right so right now you have
these comic book sites all saying like
hmm what an interesting thought what an
interesting idea and I'm seeing across
my finger saying please hath been well
yes please Seth save Star Trek the Orval
is awesome I hear the Picard show is not
very good apparently it's got good
rotten tomato scores okay what bad
everything else I have is what they talk
about so apparently one of the reasons
in the rumor that Seth was talking and
to CBS and set that NBC was because the
screener the screeners for Picard rated
really really poorly okay and the
network's
yes was like this is crazy because even
a general audience tends to like
whatever show this is yeah but Trek fans
hated it well that's pretty huge you got
to have the trek fans like it yeah but
they don't care about the core fan bases
anymore
that's the problem because here's the
thing man listen well who's watching the
show then well the idea they have is
Star Trek fans will watch it no matter
what we need to attract non Trek fans
for a bigger audience okay it doesn't
work that way well are you a Star Trek
fan absolutely you didn't watch
Discovery I know so how does that make
sense though what do you mean well I
mean they're there because they're not
watching the Star Trek fans aren't
watching the new Star Trek job because
they abandoned the core fan bases
desires for the show supposed to be and
turned into something different to
attract someone else and for me I was
like I don't watch this I thought that
was Star Trek yeah well I didn't get
into it you know because I was gonna
like but let's not let's let's read
because there's another there's another
rumor about what Seth MacFarlane would
do if he acquired Star Trek so bonding
in the comics says a new rumor details
that Seth MacFarlane and his new team at
NBC walked out of a Star Trek sales
meeting the rumor which was posted to
4chan details that MacFarlane and his
team at NBC had a meeting with CBS to
discuss the sale of Star Trek to NBC
Universal the meeting was scheduled for
two hours but ended up being done in
half an hour when McFarland & Company
walked out of the meetings the wait is
this a rumor I mean it or did this
happen it sounds like they're this
actually happened and nah dude it's
someone posting on 4chan like oh yeah
yeah you know that's probably not real
let's be honest yeah that's probably
like 4chan even says nothing on the site
is real you know like it's a disclaimer
yeah
MacFarlane and his team reportedly
walked out due to CBS's price being far
far in excess of what Seth was expecting
the poster claims Sivas price was so
high because they are emboldened by
positive reception of the card
interesting what however well done good
they do note that MacFarlane an NBC did
offer their own price and claimed it was
fair the offer allegedly included all
rights to movies and TV except those
held by bad robot CBS did not outright
reject the offer according to the poster
twitter user angry mr flibble shared the
rumor on twitter let me just stop you
right there okay you got a 4chan rumor
yeah then screen grabbed and posted to
twitter i
of flame or tremor in no way do I
believe this is real yeah no but I'm
crossing my fingers I wanted to when I
go to bed tonight
I'm gonna put my finger off my fingers
put under my pillow I'm gonna take a
silver coin put under my pillow as well
I don't know that's supposed to do but
I'm gonna do every superstitious
mishmash I can and be like please Seth
please Seth MacFarlane Orville's awesome
and you know or if I haven't seen it
it's very much like TNG like next
generation yeah yeah really like that
job yeah that was my favorite um
I'll watch Picard I need check it out
admittedly I work non-stop all day every
day so I didn't do time to do anything
it's like I want to I want to check out
the card and maybe and you know see it
for myself
I'm a Star Trek fan why don't why don't
we skip the State of the Union I mean we
should watch Picard who cares the
president has to say I mean we'll just
watch a sci-fi show and naama kidding
we're gonna watch the State of the Union
in half an hour so few thing man that's
the same they say a previous room were
also shared to 4chan and then shared to
twitter by angry mr flibble
awesome name detailed that MacFarlane
was interested in acquiring the rights
to Star Trek the rumor indicates that
CBS's Star Trek Picard was receiving
negative feedback during test screenings
the poster who claims they work for CBS
wrote first five episodes of Picard were
test screen and received an average
grade of C from general audiences and D
from Trek fans for reference even our s
East
that's the swear I guess we're on
YouTube programs will usually get a B
from general audiences although they did
note everyone is actually surprised how
good some of the influence our comments
on social media have been for the
premiere but we're putting it down to
the open bar that was in the lobby
it's yeah it's not just Picard though
the higher-ups are essing themselves
about Star Trek as a whole the show
currently is a 94% tomato meter rating
from Rotten Tomatoes I don't trust that
critics gave the show an average rating
of 8.0 six out of ten it has an 80%
audience score with the average being
four point one out of five now that I
kind of more believe more believe
there's only 800 okay yeah yeah there's
what gets weird
they say the score has an average way to
the score has an average weighted score
of eight point eight on IMDB pretty high
that's pretty high but then they say
however those numbers seem to be
massively inflated as the scores are
significantly lower for both critics and
users on Metacritic the critics
Metascore sits at 77 while the user
score
is at 6.0 with 13 positive reviews 6
mixed reviews and 8 negative reviews
that's really news but it's barely any
right so I don't I don't know why
they're gonna act like you know it look
the the Rotten Tomatoes has way more
reviews and so does the IMDB then look
this one's got thousands of good reviews
yeah I don't trust them now I gotta be
honest did you see the movies to do like
the movies the new ones the new movies a
kelvin timeline is that what it's called
the Canon timeline yeah okay right I
guess it split when the Kelvin exploded
or I think it was the USS Kelvin right
yeah yeah yeah and so you know never
goes back in time right all right I did
like them yeah
but I'm sad why they wouldn't I want to
know what happened after you know Deep
Space nine and Voyager and next
generation that whole saga well they
could revisit all of them now well no
that brings me to the next rumor that's
coming out from angry mr flibble
oh oh that's right your flip will have
about it yeah I'm gonna tell you this mr
flibble please let this be a
self-fulfilling prophecy yeah I hope he
made it up and set set they're going it
is a good idea that's a good look but
I'll be honest though the rumors do make
a lot of sense
I mean it's 4chan rumor posted a twitter
screengrab it's not yeah a lot of
credibility no but Seth clearly is a
huge fan of the of Star Trek yeah he has
the TNG characters on Family Guy all the
time he did he's doing the Orville which
people got mad though there was a funny
review that said I thought this is going
to satirize Star Trek and not be Star
Trek with some jokes in it and it's like
yeah it's the next generation yeah jokes
in hit right it's a good show yeah yeah
it makes a lot of sense because you can
clearly sees a big fan of the next
generation right that he would want to
do this now here's here's the new rumors
check this out actually I'll just jump
to mr flibble tweets let's see if I can
make this a little bit bigger apparently
I can't okay I can so this was posted a
4chan and went with the what's that oh
there we go it was posted where's the
date on this on to today I think oh no
yesterday yesterday yeah so this post
says I don't I I don't know about the
current state of the discussions between
CBS and NBC about acquiring Star Trek
from Alex Kurtzman
under Seth MacFarlane what I do know
though is that MacFarlane seems to be
working on to the impression that he'll
have the franchise by 2022
calls are
being made interviews with actors
writers and producers he's interested in
from outlines and agreements he's
already made several conclusions
he's already made several conclusions
can be drawn the Orval will not be
cancelled but if he acquires star trek
he will kill off Edie and have Kelly
take over as Captain all support for the
Orville from Seth will be cut as he
focuses on his true passion he's made it
clear the discovery lower decks
section 31 Pike and Starfleet Academy
will Academy will all get the ax prodigy
and Picard will see their full runs
under Seth he wants Scott Bakula back
for a new Star Trek project likely a
limited series
he's in talks with William Shatner and
Jonathan Frakes for a movie that would
be awesome yeah would Michael Dorn has
already said yes to heading heading his
own series okay this is like somebody
wrote down their fantasy of what they
wanted to see from Star Trek and that's
what it is hey that's okay somebody get
things done man you put it in the air
you put it in the air make a dream board
you know more flagship series will be a
new crew set in the ent era captained by
Seth MacFarlane playing a character
loosely based on himself series is
likely called Star Trek flagship unlike
previous Star Trek's he has no plan on
this series ending as long as people are
watching it he's willing to let it keep
going until he retires I don't think
anyone would be upset with that I
believe it as long as it's good I mean
no I mean here no no I said I believe it
but here's what I believe I believe this
fits Seth's character yeah yeah but I
believe someone who knows what a fan hit
fan is can easily write this up true and
if you're a big Trekkie your life want
to believe it too well but it's also
easy to write yeah and that's the thing
about a lot of leaks when it comes to
movies you can create something
plausible where people are like that
makes sense he's a fan he's a nervous
but that it has does it does seem
plausible but you know it doesn't make
sense to know what how would what would
you do at the Orval and it's a
big-budget show
well yeah it's saying it won't be
canceled but you're gonna kill off the
main character and just let it keep
broad because it's gonna move and then
you're basically coming up with yourself
on a very similar that doesn't make
sense no I don't see no real my heart is
broken
the reality is somebody's just just you
know by
tugging at our heartstrings making us
just wish I were I've watched every you
know the 90s series like several times
I haven't finished Voyager one with some
of it but I'd watch everything else but
I've watched the next generation I've
seen all this amount of time yes you
know it's like it never gets old and all
the movies I actually watched all the
original show also I didn't I watched
many of them but I'm a much bigger fan
of the next generation in the card and
so that's why I've always been upset
when they keep doing prequels yeah and
they canned an alternate timeline I'm
just like dude you created this amazing
universe and now you've just like left
it behind
yeah it's like the same thing to do with
Star Wars like they do Star Wars and
it's like everything happens at
different intervals and I'm like what is
going on yeah you're not let you're not
allowing me to like feel involved yeah
what was here's what I loved about the
next generation they did the next
generation Deep Space nine Voyager and
they're happening concurrently yeah and
then you even had Worf like going to
Deep Space nine why was the Hispanic
deeps Deep Space nine any because he
became his own captain right and he's in
the movies and so you feel like the
story's moving forward yeah what they
did with the MCU they had with the Star
Trek universe hmm and this is what's
crazy they have tried to so many studios
have tried to do what the MCU is and
failed like has anyone really created a
universe not somatic universe try really
write and see it's pretty huge and they
had Star Trek and they were like we have
this continuity we have these ideas we
have these themes these characters and
they easily could have been like let's
go for it yeah instead they're like
we'll go back in time and then Star Trek
is doing this our Star Wars does the
same thing yeah you know it really bums
me out to I'll throw this one in for
good measure
have you seen the new mummy with Tom
Cruise yeah everyone apparently like
everyone thought I was bad I liked it I
liked it I liked yeah I thought it was
cool they were gonna do the dark
universe where they were gonna revive
like Frankenstein you know whatever and
yeah they they did he was in there no no
no no I understand dr. Hyde yeah that
was awesome I thought when when Russell
Crowe like finally becomes Hyde he's
like gets his ease he stands up straight
yeah he's like his accent changes like
whoa that was cool yeah it was gonna be
a bubble universe you
in the old universe people like that
movie was that oh no but I was bummed by
that too because I was really hoping
they were gonna do the dark universe
yeah I'm gonna be I don't know maybe I'm
wrong cuz I don't I don't follow the
stuff you know as much as I felt like
news and politics but I thought it'd be
really really cool yeah they were gay
they were gonna do another series and I
think I'm supposed to like Bride of
Frankenstein yeah they finished the
movie like as if they could go on and it
was supposed to it was supposed to do
all the new you're over the old
universal horror monsters yeah mommy
cool yeah Tom Cruise is the head Knight
that'd be sweet yeah well whether or not
these rumors about Seth MacFarlane are
true we can we can all be not sure
what's gonna happen is we're all we're
all gonna you know put out a glass of
milk and cookies in the hopes that you
know old Saint Saint McFarland comes on
the chimney with new episodes of Star
Trek and a new you know following the
history with the card and everything
yeah and we're gonna curl up in our beds
and we're gonna look up at the stars I
thought our window and we're gonna like
giggle and laugh we're gonna dream about
the future again and there's gonna be a
live in Sun dling and then you're gonna
wake up to set smiling over your bed
holding a DVD or whatever it is a
digital download I don't know when
you're gonna go that doesn't go straight
to DVD Thank You Seth Star Trek alright
alright alright thanks for checking out
this segment from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show every Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. sometimes an
hour or two and we do have a full live
recorded version of the show that
includes a lot of comments and smaller
segments you probably don't see if you
want to check that out you can watch
live at 8 p.m. Monday through Friday or
become a member of this channel and for
five bucks a month you get full access
to all of the recorded podcasts every
day after the show we make them
available in the community section of
this YouTube channel so don't forget to
subscribe and stick around for more
segments and more shows Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all in the next show
you